we passed a little here and it
was impossible to restrain ourselves here, the screams were heard right into
the street, that is, when the tension
was increased, you can’t even physically be
silent in order to make it quieter, then
they dressed against you, they clamped it so that there
was no air then somehow
there was no counteraction, the scream was heard  they also fastened the battery to the battery, too, they
applied voltage for the
last days, I could no longer have my
hands, as it were, were torn off, they already stopped on the floor,
rubber, to my liking, so they
would step on their hands on their feet and the current was connected to
this woman, they held this, and they
also get naked here in the evening with them  still
had fun if the young came across
roofs in one went crazy would
start to run up in the door pancake to let
out
a person they changed hands to
hold on because any noise does not
fly out they start to knock down such cases
were someone could not stand it let go
broke
those who were especially  in poor condition, already
completely broken, they were simply taken out
and it’s not clear where it
became 445
civilized people, what kind of skin hoarding
around could not break late, the number
in wild bodies is connected not by the hand of the soundboard, the
pendulum will grow dim, that is, by the school day, the organ and
Kim can be fed cheats about the mercenary to
Vanya’s cattle I  duel Alexander Alexandrovich
this is 10 rockerzhine we are raising our son
Alexander Alexandrovich of Duvan 85 the
screw disappeared more than a month ago, the exchanges were
most likely taken by the Russians and could
shoot the
camouflage uniform of the Ukrainian army
and one maybe the jacket, maybe the trousers I don’t know
[music]
here
By the way, yes, and not that  here it’s a
little loop here they gave it to their hands,
some of them just put everything on their fingers
so that they couldn’t throw it off by the way, I
’ll never forget these particular wires,
some of them got it worse If
through the legs Let the pieces then electricity
passes Then through the whole body so only
through the upper feed  the body
was shot at some tray, for example, well, from a gun,
shoot at the feet with some of the
machine guns just near the head, he had
a hole on the wall with bullet holes, but it was someone
standing to be shot for him
I was lucky once just kept Why
[music]
because actually living